I'm inspector Kildare of Scotland Yard
I'm investigating a series of deaths
according from the Limehouse golem
murders at Ratcliffe highway he
slaughtered a household the previous
week of prostitutes and Golan de madman
even madness has its own logic
and spectacle there I may have found an
eyewitness in ly mousetrap
I can't tell you what I know just assist
me and I promise I won't let anything
I've done kill you
[Music]
who was here on September the 24th there
were four man that day John cream Dan
Lena George Gissing Karl Marx newspaper
said it was your first medication
the yard is setting me up as a scapegoat
the public want blood The Golem provides
her he who observes spills no less blood
than he inflicts the blow
it's a message to us how many more
people have to die for the goal in this
course
and keep my secret and I'll keep yours
the golem is still at large wasting my
time could cost life I believe the goal
image after me I shall stop I guarantee
we all wear pants it not love doing
[Music]
you